joining us now is dr celine gounder who
served on then president-elect biden's
transition covid19 advisory board and
she's also an epidemiologist and
infectious disease expert at the nyu
grossman school of medicine and bellevue
hospital both right here in new york
city dr gander thank you for being here
uh on behalf of the 16 million americans
who have the johnson and johnson shot uh
how should they feel about the cdc now
saying uh get another one if you can
get another one that's not johnson
johnson johnson yeah yeah if you have
not yet gotten that additional dose of
either pfizer or moderna vaccine that
really is very important now especially
with the spread of the omicron variant
we are not seeing adequate protection
with the johnson johnson vaccine alone
should they be worried about the blood
clots if they've already got the shot if
you've already had the shot if you're
within um maybe a week or two of getting
the shot there may be some concern but
if you're farther out you really are
outside the window of risk now so let's
talk big picture everyone's worried
about omicron cases are rising we're
talking about doubling every two days
but are cases really the right measure
here or should we be focused on
hospitalizations and deaths so this is a
great question i think we really need to
reframe what is a when what our
expectations are if we can turn omicron
if we can turn covid into something like
the common cold through vaccination
that's a win and we're well on our way
to doing that but everybody needs to get
vaccinated to get there i know we keep
hearing that celine but we also keep
hearing cases in new york have doubled
in the last 48 hours you see people
waiting in line for a test up to three
hours
how are we supposed to process this what
do we need to know what do we need to do
to be safe because when you hear the
cases are on the rise you think okay i'm
in trouble even if you're double vaxxed
and boosted
we are certainly seeing breakthrough
infections among people who are double
vaxxed and even boosted
but they are mild cases these are cases
of the sniffles these are not landing
people in the hospital but if you really
want to be extra safe first of all get
your two boxes and your your booster but
in addition continue to mask and use a
higher grade mask we now know those n95
or kn 95 mass are better than the
surgical and cloth mask you have less
leakage of air around your mouth
so definitely make use of those
open doors and windows have your
holiday gatherings outdoors which is
precisely what the president this is a
big weekend for holiday parties and
gathering should people even still be
having holiday parties and gatherings
under these circumstances i think it's
okay to do but really do it outdoors um
and if you're not doing it outdoors have
all the doors and windows open in the
space have one of those hepa air
filtration units in the space
and keep the numbers of people really to
a minimum hold on you said cases of the
sniffles is primarily what we're seeing
among vaccinated americans and
especially boosted americans right if
that's the case do we need people being
sent home from school sent home from the
office my daughter just got sent home
because she was recently exposed to
someone who might have had it and they
weren't even sure so that's a great
question tony it is a good question and
part of the issue is that still even in
new york city where we have high
vaccination rates 30 percent of people
are still not vaccinated and so if there
is transmission there are still people
who are very much vulnerable you have
some people who are highly
immunosuppressed who do not respond to
vaccines so having transmission in
school for example would still put
somebody like that at risk in the
beginning of the year it seems like we
were all on this boat and the waters
were rough yeah and land to us was
december yeah right getting into 2022 it
seems like we're going to finally get
over that hump we've asked this time and
time again
when will we get over this huh when will
we start to feel normal again and there
isn't such a panic when we start talking
about completely i think this all
depends on us you know if we step up if
we get i'm worried if we got to depend
on us because us ain't doing the right
thing
it's scary you know and i think we
really need to start um looking out for
one another thinking of ourselves as one
of those neighbors or you know brother's
keeper so to speak
um and that's really what will get us
over this that's hitting the fast
forward button on the pandemic is
getting vaccinated is the political
question and governor polis in colorado
made some headlines a few days ago by
saying look we have the vaccines the
emergency is over if you get sick now
it's entirely your fault
what do you think about that approach
well the challenge is if i'm a doctor
who's seeing you in the emergency room
on the wards i don't get to turn anybody
away just because they haven't been
vaccinated or they're a smoker or
whatever it is we don't treat people
that way we
welcome everybody regardless of what
they've done but aren't you frustrated
with those people it just makes it so
much more difficult for others who are
doing the right thing well trust me
we're
those of us working in the hospital are
very frustrated we're tired they deserve
care
everybody deserves care everybody
deserves you know the best we can do
right
all right happy holidays
happy holidays merry christmas merry
christmas thank you thank you for coming
in we really appreciate it